so look up at Orion today I'm seeing
like party B is canceled party on
Twitter I'm like yep people are trying
to cancel cardi B this crazy on Thursday
the hashtag cardi B is over party
started trending on Twitter after the
rapper was accused of allegedly running
a fake Instagram account to diss other
celebrities a lot of people be thinking
like it's supposed to be like a caddy
thing but cardi B was quick to shut down
the rumors I'm not a fit senior girl
they do fake instagrams to talk about
celebrities like I have a whole life I
have a whole kid I don't got time to do
like that the alleged Finn's dead count
claims to show that cardi has beef with
some female artists like little Kim
ariana grande joshi Kat and Megan D
stallion I love little Kim and I respect
her in my heart but I don't personally
know her I don't have a dollar and Randy
I don't really know her like that why
would I even talk about her I spoke
suppose you had before my team is really
cool but Meghan seen my hairstyle is
that they claimed that was on that page
is go just hair stylist and they get
along pretty well I don't have a problem
with anybody a 27 year old rapper made
it clear that she's not bothered by the
drama cardi tweeted I do feel really
powerful all I've been doing is eating
food and people have to make fake edits
to cancel me it makes me feel like I'm
that oh snap and snap snap and girl is
speaking her truth before the drama
cardi was literally minding her own
business
posting food on the ground then she
thanked her fans for always having her
back and it just feels good they don't
know how much like that means to me so
even though hashtag cardi B is over
party got debunked by the Queen herself
this fool
party B is over party that is trending
number three on Twitter all over online
can you believe it separately we gotta
go through yeah Charlie counseled me and
counseled me what is they cast me with a
boy I want me to believe my Instagram
and run and no it's not happening I just
at least fans know her new music is
coming they haven't put on music and
even once which by the way I'm putting
on music smooth and we have a feeling
cardi B has a lot to rap about here's
what she told et last year I feel like
I've been in a lot of drama I feel like
people have thrown so many things so
many different crazy obstacles a new
chapter in my life that is is I all got
a whole lot of talk about there's a lot
of things that I don't be saying that
it's like you know what every so much
time that I say it people eat me up
alive from me they say I complained so
much that you know what I'm just gonna
put it in my music there
[Music]